good morning to all of you and thank you
for being with us today
on this very important day in the state
of nevada particularly southern nevada
union workers i see so many of them in
the audience here today like frank and
his team help build nevada from the
ground up they help build our stadiums
and our resorts and they'll be integral
to the construction of our newest
project kicking off today
we built
t-mobile it was built with union labor
it was union strong and they said we
couldn't build a legion stadium the
working men and women of nevada built a
legion stadium now they're going to
build this infrastructure when there's a
problem when there's a task to be done
we turn to our union brothers and
sisters our union leadership and they
make it happen and we're forever
thankful for that
i want to start with my deep
appreciation for all the members of our
federal delegation that are here with us
today and so many of our state and local
leaders for being i'm especially
thankful to our secretary buda judge but
i want to call out
senator cortez masto senator rosen
congresswoman titus congresswoman lee
congresswoman horsford i've got
lieutenant governor kendall burkhead is
in the audience
chairman yeager is here mayor goodman's
here
treasurer conan's here we've got
everybody
fabian thank you i appreciate it they
know how important this is to our entire
community and what this means to the
working men and women
uh but we've also got christina swallow
who has shown leadership on these
projects to get them done
nevada's infrastructure would not be
what it is without your help and we
sincerely thank you for all that you've
done for us and continue to do
i'm so glad to be here to officially
announce the 15 and tropicana
interchange project which has been
decades in the making i mean decades in
terms of coming and we're so thankful
that we're really going to get started
on this
this interchange is the access point to
the world-renowned las vegas strip for
tourists and for many of our residents
commuting to and from work
if they're driving into town they're
probably going to be getting off on the
15 at tropicana
and either going to strip or straight to
legion stadium or t-mobile for an event
this is a gateway to the entertainment
and sports capital of the world
with sold out concerts here to legion
and a t-mobile just on the other side of
the i-15 and professional sporting
events at first class resorts
as many as three hundred thousand
visitors on the strip in just one
weekend three hundred thousand
that's only gonna ramp up as we host
events like formula one next year
and the super bowl in 2024
not only will hundreds of thousands of
visitors make a trip to las vegas
but these events support our economy and
provide tens of thousands of jobs for
nevadans
the stadiums already created thousands
of new jobs from construction to
transportation from small business
suppliers to technical staff it
represents one part of a more
diversified economic future
the project we kick off today will
support more than four thousand 600
construction jobs through its duration
and they know we throw these numbers
around pretty loosely you know thousand
here 500 here 4 600 there
i want you to think about 4 600 jobs
those are the most important 4
600 jobs there are to those 4 600 people
to your members who are going to have a
chance to go to work because of these
jobs they're getting put on the ground
they can support their families
take a vacation with their families buy
their kids a new backpack a pair of
shoes or they go back to school because
of our investment in infrastructure and
what our federal delegation has fought
so hard to get for us
this interchange is a main road
connecting tourists and locals alike to
the heart of las vegas
and so many major events that's why we
need to invest in safe and effective
infrastructure
this interchange
is 60 years old
almost as old as i am not quite
that wasn't meant as a joke that
it's required significant repairs over
the years
it's needed major upkeep
and reconstruction and became outdated
with all the new technology that we have
available to us today
the project will be adding safety
features like active traffic management
sides to reduce the number and severity
of crashes
the updated bridge will also make it
easier to get through traffic
for our drivers that use it in their
commute every single day
we've seen the massive crowds of people
who walk from the strip over to legion
across hacienda here across russell
with this upgrade there will be more
routes for event goers to take with
wider sidewalks and better lighting for
the walk back to their car after that
raider victory
as we prepare for major events and
increase traffic through our city in the
upcoming years we must invest now in
infrastructure that will last and be
effective as we grow
i'm proud to be here
today with secretary pete butterjudge
this project would not be possible
without your help and leadership with
the infrastructure investment and jobs
act
let me say that one more time because
it's extremely important
this project would not be possible today
without the secretary's leadership with
the infrastructure investment and jobs
act and our delegation fighting for
every one of these dollars for our state
this project is expected to start this
year
and finish in just two years
getting construction done that will have
a fast impact on our traffic and our
safety and i know us locals in las vegas
are happy it won't take very long
i want to again thank you for being here
thank you for supporting us at these
functions
and thank you on behalf of the 4 600
families they're going to have an
improved lifestyle because of union
labor
because our union brothers and sisters
can build it
and because they build it safely
and like no other city in the world can
do
so it is with my distinct honor to have
the opportunity to introduce a friend
of nevada an incredible public servant
to the united states of america
and someone who has been a champion not
just for this project for champ but for
projects nationwide and the champion for
the working men and women in the united
states of america
thank you very much for joining me and
with that i'd like to introduce united
states secretary of transportation pete
butterjudge
[Applause]
thank you governor for the kind words
thank you for your extraordinary
leadership thank you for your
understanding of the importance of
infrastructure
and challenging
us to make sure we meet the pace that
you have set here at the state level
together with the terrific work director
swallow that you and your colleagues at
n-dot are doing
that frankly didn't
wait for solutions to come from
washington
to get the ball rolling to lay the
literal groundwork so that now
now that we have been able to deliver
this infrastructure investment and jobs
act nevada is poised to take such quick
and effective advantage of those dollars
thank you to everybody who's part of
this
union leadership business leadership
people who understand
that we're not just
building stadiums or
highways when you have these kinds of
construction jobs you're building a
living
for people in nevada and around the
country i want to thank senator cortez
masto and senator rosen congressman
horsford congressman lee the
congresswoman lee
and congresswoman titus who joined us by
video i'll have more to say about them
in a moment but i just want to open by
making clear that their support is
directly the reason why we see this
extraordinary infrastructure investment
happening in nevada and around the
country they have done so much to make
it possible for us to have the tools
that were just talked about by congress
after congress administration after
administration infrastructure week after
infrastructure week and now we are
beginning a true
infrastructure decade and you can see it
all around us
i want to thank all of the leaders from
the local and the state level the mayor
and everyone who has helped to
demonstrate what it looks like when
people team up to get results
and frank i want to thank you and and
the carpenters for everything that you
and and
all the building trades have been doing
in order to make this region a model for
economic development that benefits
people
i got to tell them having some very
strong memories uh coming back to las
vegas not just because of the many
visits that i was making here a couple
of years ago when i got to know many of
you well but because of the last time i
was here it was in august i was all set
to do a whole bunch of events we had
that uh that great event with uh
with congresswoman lee celebrating the
the work we're going to do to enhance
safety on the boulder highway and during
that trip i got
the most disruptive and wonderful phone
call of my life we had been on a list
for better part of a year
hoping for a chance to expand our family
through adoption
and got the call and it was one of those
surprise kind of calls that had me on an
airplane as quick as i could be in the
next morning jason and i were holding
our newborn infant twins in our arms
so
so i just have all these strong feelings
when i come back here because i have
these associations with with something
that changed everything in my life and i
think about everything that's changed
since then like every parent
my world has been turned upside down
like every parent i have a different
relationship to the future now now that
i spend every day training my
replacement in this world
i think about the infrastructure that
we're building that they're going to
count on for the rest of their lives
and of course i've been thinking about
everything that has changed even just in
that short less than a year since i was
here last for this community because
back then we were still selling the idea
of that bipartisan infrastructure law
and some of the members of of the house
and senate mentioned it was declared
dead many times last year before they
saw it through and the president signed
it on the south lawn of the white house
in november some six months ago and now
here we are in a place that is
experiencing such extraordinary growth
in jobs in population in economic
activity which brings a lot of
challenges to support that growth with
adequate infrastructure to keep it going
and of course communities that have
faced the ups and downs more
dramatically even than most around the
united states in the last couple years
and met them admirably
again under the governor's leadership
laying the groundwork pun intended for
uh the the kind of work that we see
funding for the first time the state's
infrastructure bank moving forward on
important projects like the one that
we're seeing today
and then we have this federal work that
that we're so proud of we are helping
communities across america improving
their infrastructure with roads and rail
trains and transit ports and airport
improvements internet water systems it's
the biggest effort of this kind in the
better part of a century we've already
announced almost a billion dollars
headed to nevada specifically and that's
just the beginning
and that's what brings us here today to
this terrific project and and so i'm
thrilled to join the governor and
leaders here uh to celebrate the
beginning of work on this i-15 tropicana
interchange we're going to replace the
old bridge improve access ramps double
the width of the sidewalks add advanced
traffic safety features that are known
to reduce crashes bottom line
dramatically improve people's travel
into and out of the las vegas trip
i know a lot of people have been
spending the last couple years
on zoom but as we've all felt now more
than ever real connection
real economic growth happens when people
are together
las vegas knows that so well
and to be in person one way or the other
you have to move you have to travel
maybe it's just down the street maybe
it's from another state maybe it's on
foot maybe it's by car
you have to get from one place to
another and when we rely on generations
old infrastructure to try to meet the
needs of today let alone to try to
prepare for the dreams of the future it
leaves us
wanting it leaves us less safe it leaves
us less efficient and it limits our
economic potential that's what we're
fixing today we're improving a road
design that was set up long before las
vegas looked the way that it did today
and so modernizing this intersection is
going to help more people get to where
they need to go more safely more
efficiently and more reliably
and people get something else back
that's that's right along in my view
ranks right alongside the dollars and
cents that are going to be brought into
the economy and brought into family
budgets through this work
people are going to get time back in
their day
the only thing that we have at the end
of the day time spent with loved ones
time
to think about what matters instead of
being stuck in traffic
that's so important alongside the
importance of these jobs the over 4 000
jobs that were so
pleased to see that are directly
connected to this
project but of course there are all of
the indirect jobs that are going to
benefit from this as well later today
i'm going to be at the carpenter's
training center meeting with a number of
representatives from the unions there
and the people who are literally
building america's future and operating
it and maintaining it with those good
paying jobs that can become good paying
careers but we would not be here if it
weren't for the leadership of the folks
you see on the stage with me and so
again i want to thank governor sislek
for making clear that infrastructure
would be a priority and for recognizing
the importance of transportation and of
infrastructure in creating not just
physical assets but livelihoods i want
to thank senators cortez masto and
senator rosen for their work in shaping
this legislation and believing in it
through all of these times when uh when
it has gone through those ups and downs
and seeing it through and you should
know
that they do not hesitate to get a hold
of me when there is any opportunity they
can think of for federal dollars to
benefit the state of nevada as i would
expect and it's very much to your
benefit
representatives horseford and lee and
titus who were there from the beginning
who knew why this was going to be so
important and stepped up in a moment
when a lot of people were skeptical of
the idea you could get a bipartisan
anything law done in today's washington
in today's divided washington and yet
here we are
so uh so successful that we're seeing
what i consider to be the sincerest form
of flattery in the policy world which is
people who didn't support it uh wanting
to be there to help celebrate the good
projects that are getting done and are
getting initiated
thanks to this legislation
now the only thing that is that the
former mayor in me loves more than a
groundbreaking is a ribbon cutting and
so what i'm really looking forward to
over the course of the months and years
to come is seeing these
extraordinary efforts come to completion
and then most importantly of all seeing
the lives that are going to benefit from
this work it's not about the
transportation itself unless you're
an infrastructure buff like me it's
about the lives that are going to be
improved and here in in this community
whether it's for the people who come and
go from this community the people uh who
have been here all their lives uh that's
what this is ultimately going to do it's
going to make everyday life safer it's
going to make everyday life a little bit
better and it's going to make this
country stronger in the process thanks
again for everything that you're doing
so glad
[Applause]